JET TO OUR NATION'S CAPITAL WILL
BREAK DOWN THE MULTIPLE LAYERS
OF HYPOCRISY.
THAT'S COMING UP.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, HE IS THE
LEFT-WING NEW GREENDALE
SOCIALIST, MOST CHERISHED PUBLIC
FIGURE.
LONGTIME GOVERNMENT DOCTOR, WHO
IS OFTEN WRONG, BUT NEVER IN
DOUBT.
ANTHONY FLIP-FLOP FLOW SHEET IS
ONCE AGAIN BACK IN THE NEWS
AFTER SENATOR RAND PAUL OF
KENTUCKY, WHO IS ALSO A MEDICAL
DOCTOR CONFRONTED FAUCI ABOUT
HIS DECEPTIVE TESTIMONY
SURROUNDING WHAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
A LOT.
IT'S CALLED GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH AND THE WUHAN INSTITUTE
OF VIROLOGY.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ORIGINS OF
COVID-19.
AS A REMINDER, THE DEFINITION OF
GAIN OF FUNCTION, THAT RESEARCH
OFTEN INVOLVES MANIPULATING
VIRUSES TO MAKE THEM MORE
DANGEROUS, MORE INFECTIOUS.
NOW IT FAUCI'S NIH DEFINES
ITSELF.
THIS IS THEIR DEFINITION.
RESEARCH PROJECTS THAT CAN BE
REASONABLY ANTICIPATED TO
ENHANCE TRANSMISSIBILITY VIA THE
RESPIRATORY ROUTE IN MAMMALS.
THE PRACTICE IS SO RISKY THAT IT
WAS TEMPORARILY HALTED FROM
2014-2017.
THIS HIGHLY DANGEROUS RESEARCH
APPARENTLY CONTINUED AT THE
WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
THEY SPENT MILLIONS OF YOUR U.S.
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO THIS WUHAN
LAB FUNNELED TO A NONPROFIT
THAT'S CALLED ECO-HEALTH
ALLIANCE.
NOW PUT SIMPLY, FAUCI'S NIH MAY
HAVE PLAYED A ROLE IN DEVELOPING
THE DEADLY COVID-19 VIRUS.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING WE NEED
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF.
BECAUSE NOW ACCORDING TO
MULTIPLE OUTLETS, INCLUDING
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," A
WUHAN LAB LEAK IS THE MOST
LIKELY BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
THAT HAS KILLED MILLIONS
WORLDWIDE.
BUT TODAY, WHEN ASKED ABOUT THIS
VERY REAL POSSIBILITY,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI BECAME MORE
INDIGNANT, MORE DEFENSIVE THAN
EVER.
EVEN CALLED SENATOR AND
DR. RAND PAUL, SAID HE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT HE'S TALKING ABOUT.
BUT I THINK IT WAS HIM THAT
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU DECIDE.
>> DR. FAUCI, KNOWING THAT IT IS
A CRIME TO LIE TO CONGRESS, DO
YOU WISH TO RETRACT HER
STATEMENT WERE YOU CLAIMED THATE
NIH NEVER FUNDED RESEARCH IN
WUHAN?
>> SENATOR PAUL, I HAVE NEVER
LIED BEFORE THE CONGRESS AND I
DO NOT RETRACT THAT STATEMENT.
THIS PAPER THAT YOU ARE
REFERRING TO WAS JUDGED BY
QUALIFIED STAFF UP AND DOWN THE
CHAIN AS NOT BEING GAIN OF
FUNCTION.
LET ME FINISH.
>> TAKEN ANIMAL VIRUS AND YOU
INCREASE TRANSMISSIBILITY TO
HUMANS, YOU ARE SAYING THAT IS
NOT --
>> SENATOR PAUL, YOU DO NOT KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT QUITE
FRANKLY.
THE ONE AND THEN HE READ THE
NIH'S OWN DEFINITION OF GAIN OF
FUNCTION.
NOW IF ALL OF DR. FAUCI'S
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES UP AND
DOWN THE CHAIN, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS SAY IT WASN'T TECHNICALLY
GAIN A FUNCTION RESEARCH, WELL
THEN, I GUESS IT SETTLED.
HE'S JUST TOTALLY OFF THE HOOK.
WHILE ACCORDING TO A VISIBLY
SHAKEN DR. FAUCI, YEAH,
SENATOR PAUL IS JUST PROPAGATING
WHAT IS CALLED A DANGEROUS LIE.
YOU DECIDE.
>> IF THE POINT THAT YOU ARE
MAKING IS THAT THE GRANT THAT
WAS FUNDED AS A SUB AWARD FROM
ECO-HEALTH TO WUHAN CREATED
SARS, LET ME FINISH.
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
ALL THE EVIDENCE IS POINTING
THAT IT CAME FROM THE LAB.
THERE WILL BE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THOSE THAT FUNDED THE LAB
INCLUDING YOURSELF.
>> I TOTALLY --
I TOTALLY RESENT THE LIE THAT
YOU ARE NOW PROPAGATING,
SENATOR.
>> Sean: PROPAGATING A
DANGEROUS LIE.
REALLY?
HERE IS HOW SENATOR RAND PAUL
RESPONDED.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE VIRUSES
THAT WERE USED IN THE
EXPERIMENTS THAT WERE GIVEN IN
THE ANNUAL REPORTS THAT WERE
PUBLISHED INTO LITERATURE, IT IS
MOLECULARLY IMPOSSIBLE.
>> NO ONE IS SAYING --
>> IT IS MOLECULARLY --
>> WHAT WE ARE ALLEGING IS THE
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH WAS
GOING ON IN THAT LAB AND THE NIH
FUNDED IT.
IT MEETS YOUR DEFINITION.
>> Sean: IT DOES MEET HIS VERY
DEFINITION.
DR. FAUCI THOUGHT IT WAS CUTE.
HE'S PLAYING WORD GAMES IN ORDER
TO ESCAPE ANY CULPABILITY OR ANY
RESPONSIBILITY HERE THIS IS VERY
SERIOUS.
WHY ON EARTH WAS ANTHONY FAUCI'S
NIA SENDING ANY MONEY WHATSOEVER
TO ANY VIROLOGY LAB IN CHINA?
WHO IN THEIR RIGHT MIND WOULD
EVER THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA?
AND WHY IS PHOTIUS STILL SERVING
IN THE WHITE HOUSE?
FORGET ABOUT THE GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH CLAIMS FOR A
MOMENT.
DR. FAUCI'S SLOPPY GUIDANCE
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN ALL
OVER THE MAP.
HE HAS FLIPPED.
HE HAS FLOPPED.
HE HAS FAILED THE ENTIRE TIME.
HE IS TRASHING CHINA'S DRACONIAN
LOCKDOWN.
BUT ON MARCH 13TH, HE PROMOTED A
14 DAY NATIONAL LOCKDOWN IN THE
U.S. TO SLOW THE SPREAD, WHICH
TURNED INTO SEVERAL MONTHS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD.
THEN ON JANUARY 28TH, 2020,
FAUCI DOWNPLAYED THE
ASYMPTOMATIC SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS.
IN AUGUST OF THE SAME YEAR, HE
BLAMED ASYMPTOMATIC CASES FOR
COMMUNITY OUTBREAKS.
LAST YEAR, HE REFERRED TO TRUMP
RALLIES AS TROUBLESOME,
SUPER-SPREADER EVENTS.
HE HAD NOT A WORD TO SAY ABOUT
LAST SUMMER'S PROTESTS AND
RIOTS.
NOTHING.
ON MASKS, WHILE FIRST FAUCI LEFT
AT THE IDEA ON "60 MINUTES."
TOLD US NOT TO WEAR ANY MASKS.
THEY DON'T WORK.
THEN HE DEMANDED WE ALL WEAR ONE
MASK INDOORS AND ALSO A MASK
OUTDOORS.
TWO MASKS.
THEN NO MASK OUTDOORS.
AND NOW WE MAY BE WEARING MASKS
IN PERPETUITY.
WE CAN GO ON, AND ON, AND ON,
AND ON.
NOW HERE ARE A FEW MORE
EXAMPLES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE WAS NO NEED TO CHANGE
ANYTHING THAT YOU ARE DOING ON A
DAY-BY-DAY BASIS.
RIGHT NOW THE RISK IS STILL LOW.
>> IT IS BAD NOW.
I THINK THESE NUMBERS ARE SO
STUNNING.
>> IF YOU ARE A HEALTHY YOUNG
PERSON, THERE IS NO REASON.
IF YOU WANT TO GO ON A
CRUISE SHIP TO GO ON A
CRUISE SHIP.
>> IT IS NOT A GOOD IDEA TO
TRAVEL.
BACK IN THE UNITED STATES.
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE WALKING
AROUND WITH MASKS.
>> WELL, IF ONE MASK IS GOOD,
AND MAKES COMMON SENSE THAT
MAYBE TWO MASKS ARE BETTER.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE EVOLUTION
OF THE VIRUS IN BATS AND WHAT'S
OUT THERE NOW, IT'S VERY, VERY
STRONGLY LEANING TOWARDS THIS
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN ARTIFICIALLY
OR DELIBERATELY MANIPULATED.
>> DO YOU FEEL CONFIDENT THAT IT
DEVELOPS NATURALLY?
>> NO, I AM NOT CONVINCED ABOUT
THAT.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO INVESTIGATE WHAT WENT ON IN
CHINA.
>> Sean: HE WAS WRONG ON
CRUISES.
HE WAS WRONG ALL OVER THE PLACE
WITH MASKS, HERE, THEY ARE, AND
EVERYWHERE.
AND OF COURSE TREATMENTS.
HE WAS WRONG ON HOW THE DISEASE
IS TRANSMITTED.
HIS REJECTIONS WERE A DISASTER
AND HIS NIH WAS SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC.
SO WHY ON EARTH IS DR. FAUCI
EVEN STILL EMPLOYED?
AND WHERE ARE THE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO HIS POTENTIAL -- BUT WHAT
ABOUT THOSE EMAILS THAT NOW TELL
US A LOT MORE ABOUT WHAT HE KNEW
AS EARLY AS JANUARY 31ST OF 2020
MR. MARKEY WAS TOLD THAT IT
LOOKED LIKE A SPECIFIC GENOME
MIGHT HAVE BEEN MANIPULATED IN
AN EMAIL.
THE FRANTIC EMAI